need to resume this series we're not in
iowa anymore
no i mean look the the iowa impression
is left i mean it's memorable there's no
question but we come back home to
guaranty rate field to a packed house
this is awesome i'm ready for some
regular old-fashioned baseball let's go
hard-throwing right-hander dylan cease
is set to work against dj lemayhew brett
gardner and aaron judge
2-2
skied the other way
and it's gonna be a base hit up against
the wall
goodwin plays it poorly kind of rolls
around on the uh warning track but
staying in second with the lead off
double is lemay here
and now gardner pulls this one to right
with goodwin back with space
to make the catch on the track
lemay hugh tags and advances and there's
one away
[Music]
this should do the job
the catch is made by robert tagging is
lame he'll score easily and it's
one-nothing x
the yankees take a one-nothing lead on
the ribby sac fly by judge well here is
joey gallo
now the one two is swung on and it high
in the ear to right field goodwin going
back is on the track he's on the wall
she's gone joey gallo homers over the
right field fence the yankees take a two
nothing lead he's pal joey and he homers
to right field it's been a problem for
stanton that pitch in that spot the one
two and he swings through another slider
as cease comes back with a k
two runs in the first for the yankees
and jamison tayo gonna make his 23rd
start there in chicago tonight you can
see the numbers rounding into form only
34 walks
the 2-2 is swung on and hit high in the
air to shallow right
judge kind of walks in to make the catch
one away
and the pitch is lying out in the left
center for a base hit
anderson will make the turn and end up
at third jose the second he's got a
double
i'll tell you what
he took a chance
and it paid off got the right man up
there fingers crossed
jimenez jimenez on the ground it knicks
up at tyoon and le mayhew throws out
jimenez but anderson scores and the sox
are on the board here in the first
chop
right to odor
and over the point to get the final out
here comes the payoff pitch
that is strike three call
in the air to left sending alloy jimenez
to the track on the run to make the
catch
for out number two
[Applause]
this is hit well in the air to center as
robert retreats spins around back pedals
and makes the catch
breaking ball is popped up by goodwin
there's lemayo on the edge of the
outfield grass to make the catch one
away one of the things that has to
happen is luis robert has to get his
timing back
2-2 to him
and he hits this one well to center
gardner is back at the wall it is gone
right on cue for luis robert it's a tie
ball game and this is what he brings to
the table a gold glove in center field
and a guy with enormous power
now the 2-2
is a breaking ball lying to right center
field in the gap it's a base hit
cut off by robert no it goes all the way
to the wall
gardner is going to get a triple out of
it
somebody
it went past robert and then brian
goodwin missed in back of him and it
went all the way to the screen so
gardner at third with two men out and
that will bring up aaron
judge sliced the other way there's a
base hit that's going to go to the wall
scoring easily as gardner and judge is
going for two he will make it with an
rbi double and the yankees lead three to
two 2-2
cut out and miss he went fastball again
with 99 and he strikes out gallow
2-2 pitch
this is pulled to left and struck well
gallow dogs it cannot get it
it goes to the wall hernandez will get
stopped at third on a bullet from abreu
so jimenez bats again with runners at
second and third and one out two two
pitch
arroyo drills this one the left center
field toward the alley and back to the
wall and gardner makes the catch
hernandez tags to tie the game on a long
sac fly from malloy jimenez
hold on the ground to the backhand of
cesar hernandez and a pick
for jose abreu
this is bounce towards second
easier for hernandez this time and he
throws out le mayhew and that is the
changeup
and he gets gardner out in front of it
again in the 70s for cease who knocks
his way off the mound
let's chop it short there's one on to
first not in time
so anderson reaches on the fielder's
choice
1-0 pitch
pops this one up
up the first base line the infield fly
rule in effect and it lands foul
the lights haven't taken over yet this
is dusk
and when both voigt and agashioka looked
up in the air they couldn't see anything
that would score no play
this could be two there's one on the
first it's a double play ready for a
one-two when fastball fastball tried the
slider and now gets judge swinging on a
chain jump
cut out and missed oh crochet tied him
up with a heck of a slider
he strikes out voigt with a changeup and
crochets fired up so brings up brian
goodwin
grounded to voight
and everybody's safe no they got him
they got him daryl boston the first base
coach said safe but the first base
umpire mike estabrook
called them out it is a 3-3 tie bottom
of the six andrew vaughan who's come out
to pinch him
broken back slow ground ball they're
gonna come home they'll get the force
it's a 3-3 tie so collins with two outs
bases loaded in the sixth inning
fly ball
left center going back gardener he's on
the track he makes the play at the wall
to end the inning so gardner comes up on
a 3-2
he struck him out
they've got two on here in the seventh
with two down for joan
there's a ground ball
2-0 door he's going to go across the
diamond and he gets monkato judge won
for six off of kimbrell
wise that one is a home run
that one is ripped into center field on
the run is robert turning looking sia a
home run to center a solo shot for judge
and the yankees lead four to three
aaron judge now rounds third and
everyone rise here comes the judge front
gardner with runners on second and third
and two out
a roller to first abreu secures it white
sox down to their final out jose abreu
three two
abrasive skies it left field
tie ball game
are you kidding me
that's four hits tonight for jose's 24th
home run would you have it any other way
moving to third is brett gardner on the
ball on the dirt well here's judge
and the pitch is lined to
left center field there's a base hit and
the yankees take a 5-4 lead gallow a
home run solo shot in the first inning
drill deep to right there it goes if
it's fair it's gone it is
gone see ya a long home run for gallow
and the yankees lead seven to four
four pitch walk to bring the timer on to
the plate
first pitch swinging and it's lined past
the door into center
jimenez scores and it's a two-run ball
game sebby looks like he's grabbed a bat
but the base is loaded
that is punched out to first base they
get the out all the runners get back
well it sets up yet another hollywood
ending for tim anderson
[Music]
ground ball
right away goes to second gets the force
and abraham does the job and the yankees
hold on and they win 7-5